c'est peu avant 22h et juste après la
prestation d elie jay que l'orage a
débuté pas devant mais une pluie fine
qui s'est transformée rapidement en
trombes d'eau sur les quatre mille
festivaliers évacuation de lula est
grande la plus grande partie du parc et
à ce moment là la pluie qui a redoublé
et là le niveau de l'eau qui a monté un
an gros ici il y avait avait 20
centimètres d'eau vers les festivaliers
ont été évacués dans le calme une partie
ont été évacués par les sorties qui
était prévu il est ensuite comme ça
redouble et c'est devenu très très fort
ils ont été abritées par tous sur les
barres nam où il y avait de la place
la à l'école de musique et ensuite ce
que vous avez vu dans le au centre de
loisirs dans les salles aujourd'hui les
bénévoles termine deux rangées de
nettoyer et cet épisode orageux n'a pas
laissé de stigmates sur le site du
festival
ce n'est pas le cas au gymnase de la
commune bâtiment d'à peine 3 ans dont la
salle principale était inondé une
conduite d'eau de pluie a lâché on
suppose que c'est un tuyau d'évacuation
qui a
qui a lâché enfin alors après les
explications on les aura dans le temps
mais pour le moment au vu de la pression
d'eau d'hier soir je pense que c'est ça
mais voilà mais c'est le bas de la
commune le quartier de la bonnerie qui a
été le plus touché l'eau et la boue se
sont infiltrés dans certaines maisons
cet agriculteur à vue à des trombes
d'eau s'est déversée dans sa cour à
c'est la surprise j'ai jamais connue
c'est tellement venu vite en une
demi-heure l'eau allait monter de 80 cm
on est dans un creux ici voilà et bon
lot assez cool dans le temps l'oas et
courir à s'écouler naturellement sur les
mots donc là il ya des mais tout ça les
maisons ça n'existait pas non ici
construit des maisons donc lofo gala
fall a drainé ça allait dans ces buses
là et voilà quoi la maire de la commune
était toujours en relation avec les
habitants pour tenter de faire un
premier bilan de ces intempéries